heute in genau zwei wochen ist es soweit
am 19 november starten wir auf eine
fünfwöchige reise durch die usa nach
toronto und nach mexiko und auf unserem
weg werden wir schulen und universitäten
besuchen die deutsch unterrichten
wir werden viele neue videos produzieren
wir werden unsere patrons treffen und
wir werden auch mit ups ausrichten in
denen ihr uns treffen können
für uns ist diese zeit eine ganz
besondere zeit denn für fünf wochen
werden wir zu viert jeden tag zusammen
sein janisch easy ben und ich es wird
also eine sehr intensive zeit und
gleichzeitig wissen wir von unseren
erfahrungen zum beispiel von unseren
früheren besuchen in den usa in japan
oder in vietnam wie sehr diese zeit wie
intensiv die zeit ist und wie prägend
diese zeit ist denn wenn wir unterwegs
sind und viele von euch treffen dann
hilft uns das nicht nur andere kulturen
kennenzulernen sondern es hilft uns auch
eine ganz neue perspektive auf
deutschland die deutsche kultur und die
deutsche sprache zu gewinnen und am ende
schafft es auch einfach wahnsinnig viel
motivation und inspiration
neue videos zu machen und neue themen
anzugehen
für euch gibt es drei möglichkeiten uns
auf dieser tour zu begleiten
erstens könnt ihr uns bei youtube und
bei instagram folgen und dort werdet ihr
natürlich wie immer 200 pro woche neue
videos sehen und auch manchmal instagram
stories sehen
zweitens könnt ihr uns vor ort treffen
wir werden mit ups organisieren unter
anderem in chicago detroit downtown los
angeles und mexiko city und ihr könnt
einfach auf unsere facebook seite gehen
die verlinken wir hier unter dem video
und dort findet ihr alle informationen
zu den daten und auch zu den orten wo
wir uns treffen werden und das dritte
ist etwas ganz neues was wir zum ersten
mal
werden denn zum ersten mal überhaupt
wehren werden wir während dieser tour
tägliche videos produzieren damit ihr
euer deutsche bekannt aber auch mit uns
interagieren könnt das ganze gibt es für
unsere mitglieder auf bachelor und zwar
nur exklusiv in der patch vep wir laden
euch also ein
bis zum november ein mitglied auf vettel
zu werden und an unserer reise
teilzuhaben dort gibt es ein feature das
heißt lenz und dadurch könnt ihr jeden
tag kurze videos sehen aber auch uns
schreiben und wir werden viel von
unserer reise berichten aber auch fragen
an erstellen kleine übungen zusammen
machen und wir freuen uns sehr wenn ihr
dabei seid also am 9 november geht es
los bis dahin könnt ihr noch ein
mitglied von the german bei katrin
werden und dann könnt ihr dabei waren
bei unserer täglichen deutsch challenge
jeden tag ein kleines video oder mehrere
kleine videos und wir freuen uns sehr
wenn ihr dabei seid egal ob online oder
offline wir freuen uns wahnsinnig euch
zu treffen und das wird für uns eine
ganz besondere zeit
jazz und bis bald